We want you to develop a mindset of being both curious and skeptical, when
you work with data. To help you get into this mindset, I want to share
another conversation that I had with Aude. In this next video, I want you
to listen to Aude's work and look
out for how she demonstrated this exact mindset.
>> So we gathered all the home towns and current cities from the
users and I was looking at conditional probabilities given
a hometown. What is the probability that you currently live
in each different cities? Like, for example given that your
hometown is New York, what is the probability that you
live in Chicago or that you live in, that you
still live in New York or that you live in
San Francisco or Paris and so on. And what I
was expecting is that, at least, the most likely city,
where you would live right now would be the city where
your home town is. If you grew up in
Chicago, the most likely place that you're going to
be now is still Chicago. You could be moving
as well but the most likely place would remain your
hometown. But I saw a fair number of cases
where the most likely current city was different from
the home town and, and that was, was a
fairly high probability. I was really surprised. I was wondering
if I had, had a prime in my computations, If there was some issues upstream of
what I was doing. So I decided to put all the cities on a map. All the pairs of
hometowns and current cities for which the most
likely current city was different from the hometown. And
what we saw on this map was really fascinating
because it was really not what we we're expecting.
It was not a bug in the code. We were really seeing patterns arise. Here we only
plotted pairs of hometown and current city, so
there's no movement between the pairs but what we
see is that a lot of these cities for which the most likely
current city is different from the hometown arise in western Africa or in
India or in like Turkey, which we were not
necessarily expecting at the beginning. And there were a
lot of small cities all moving to the same current
city and so we decided to dig a bit
more into it. One thing that happens is that sometimes
the distribution of the current city is very flat.
Given that you grew up in, let's say Paris, maybe
you're still living in Paris but maybe you live in
like one of the thousand cities in the suburbs and
so the distribution is really flat and so we
have to decide what was considered as a coordinates
demarcation. We decided yeah, the probability to move to
that city is high enough that we're considering that.
And the other thing we have to think about is that if you look at the map at
the world scale or if you zoom to a
very specific area, you don't want to see the same things.
So,we also want it to have interactivity in the visualization. And so we
decided to use D3, which is a Javascript-based visualization framework, which
enables you to have a lot of interactivity with with your data
and enabled us to do a lot of that exploration and so on.